greetings from podcast Ville it's Monday
November 4th the church what's happening
now is brought to you by for hymns joy
wits for hymns a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men let me explain some t-62 6% of men
start to lose their hair by the age of
35 and once you know there's nothing
here it could be too late
all right I mean it's that hemline
slowly starting to move backwards and he
bald spots how's your erectile
disfunction these type of day listen
this is what for hems does they're
one-stop shop what you do is there's no
snake oil pills no gas station counter
supplements this connects you with real
doctors online which could save you
hours completely confidential and
discreet fix this Thanksgiving when your
relatives say healthy and full they're
finally gonna be talking about your hair
and not the turkey not to mention they
don't know about your [ __ ] dick law
rod but listen you know and that's the
most important thing you start to notice
these things you don't do something
about them they're gonna get out of
control do me a favor go to forums calm
right now the church family can get
started with hymns complete a kit for
just $5 you saying Joey what are you
talking 5 hours today while supplies
last and subject the doctor's approval
see website for full details and safety
information listen to me four hymns is
gonna work out for you because this
could cause few hundred and if you went
to a doctor or pharmacy or somewhere
else
you're going deep deep deep into your
pockets when your food for him is calm
we're gonna save so do me a favor go to
400 doc Tom slash Church slash Joey I'm
sorry Jo ey that's for M's dot-com slash
Joey again for hims calm listen let's
stop the hair loss let's stop the sexual
problems let's go to for him just calm
right now and slash Joey the church is
also brought to you by CBD line back Tom
listen everybody everybody wants to know
about CBD
uncle Joey's here to tell you CBD lyin
calm go to the website read start
learn third party test results whether
you want to drink it eat it in a gummy
smoke it the what listen CBD lions got
your covered they got a pamphlet and
they even tell you a certain see what
CBD they get for your ailment no other
company goes that type that BP
understand isn't do me a favor for the
CBD lines doctor I'm right now impress
in church and get 20% off your first
daughter listen to me how many more
weeks if you learned a valuable lesson
last week you learn on Saturday night
Nick Diaz whatever his name is Nate Diaz
was the underdog getting 120 everybody
their mother bet Nate Diaz
you've never seen a bookie with a
part-time job maybe you're like mozz
Devon you held back cuz you didn't know
you know where to put your action in
listen my bookie football seasons here
basketball seasons here
you're like winning money and you want
to sit down and watch TV like a [ __ ]
Mookie and onion dip like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting fatter by the day cut it
out listen if you're gonna sit there and
watch your mom's won't make a lot of
money you got the NFL you got UFC you
got Bella whatever my bookies got it
they got better incentives and more
lines than any other sports book period
so do me a favor right now it's [ __ ]
Monday morning let's start off with a
[ __ ] bang double your first deposit
right now today use promo code Church CH
you are CH to get 100% bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 that's my
bookie that AG today visit them right
now let's cut the [ __ ] my bo o ki e dot
AG and don't forget to use promo code
Church when creating your account to
claim the bonus and listen check the
Instagram on Thursday there'll be
something there for you I'll give you a
pic to let you [ __ ] teach you
something that you don't know my bookie
dot AG kick this [ __ ] mealy
thank you very much for joining me on a
Monday [ __ ] morning first
Monday at am on solo edition podcast
wanna break it down to three segments
I'm getting you the [ __ ] in and out of
here today but let's kick off with the
elephant in the room just so you see
hope listen man I use
as a science project and you looked you
watch you study and you learn three
years ago we had Georgia Mazda varnish
or four years ago nobody know what the
[ __ ] the kid was you know he had one a
few lost a few he's got a couple of
exciting things but nobody knew what the
[ __ ] kid was he booked the trip he
booked the show South America's man just
set them down and it clear his head and
you heard it from his mouth
that he realized he wasn't that he was
leaving up to the referees you know
couple months back we spoke about a
situation called frustration when you
just get frustrated with yourself and
you break the Mary's you know George a
Mazda Valle knew he had now for starters
I did not bet this I did not pick a side
you know I like Nate Diaz as a fighter I
love Fannin eight years a fine and I'm a
personal friend of George's so for me to
come on the podcast and stop yelling
screaming I just watched as a fan
it's really weird what's happened to me
the last year ever since my gambling
days I never really watched sports
because I only sports to me meant
gambling but guess what over the last
couple of years I'm not gonna whine
nobody have watched a couple basketball
series at the end I'm big at the end I'm
bigger the playoffs you know the Final
Four
you know the baseball world series I've
watched all seven games which is very
rare for me it's good just to become a
fan again and with Emma Mayen and like
everything else I was looking at has my
past this time I just wanted to watch in
fact I watched the fight at home my wife
my wife is a father you know
Maslov all came over the house she loves
Nate but the depth of that I you know we
watched it and you know for you people
who are in a part in your life whether
it's school or your business or whatever
listen you always have the tools
available to you it's just putting them
all together you know listen how many
times I open up my Twitter and I see
somebody put a spider-man picture up me
facing dark or me running in the long
issue well guess what that was 2003 in
2004 I was 15 [ __ ] years ago
so you think I just popped up in 2010
because Rogan said I was funny is
something like that you mean you're
mistakenly wrong this journey started in
91 I had the pieces to become a good
comic maybe in 98 I just didn't listen
him one of my own beaten path but uh I
caught myself and I stuck to the plan
and even if it took 18 15 years I'd
caught myself and I did something with
it with Mazda violet took I mean Emily
fights said he had 40s he said 40 fights
already 20 and some [ __ ] black dudes
backyard that this our [ __ ] booze on
the [ __ ] line [ __ ] like that I mean
so you get frustrated you get sick and
tired of where you are in life and you
do something about it he's used to fight
or the [ __ ] year and they said it
last night it's amazing when you see
this because all of us have these this
gifts we all have this and we'll sit
back and go oh I wish I did that we all
have the tools it's putting them
together all in one shot the stars
aligning and you really really really
taking a deep look at yourself and being
honest I'm gone
listen you know I'm doing this this is
good but I'm missing the point in three
different fields here I'm missing what
I'm supposed to be doing I'm gonna put
more emphasis on this and more emphasis
on this and forget about this and write
this off this just doesn't work at all
in my life it takes a big man to do that
it takes a man to do that to somebody
looking within and go this is not
[ __ ] working you don't need anybody
to tell you and sometimes some of you
come to you as a friend and try to tell
you hey this thing ain't working and
you'll get mad at him or whatever figure
insecurities but you know when
something's not working nobody has to
tell you you know when something's not
right inside you so I want to
congratulate George I want to
congratulate Nate
for a great [ __ ] fight I mean a lot
of people disappointed hey we weren't
there we don't know what that cut like I
told Rover on the phone this morning I
don't know what that doctor saw I know
years ago when I was a kid a friend of
mine that caught with a bob why he was
playing baseball as I'm shedding I
caught with a bob why ever some and it
cut the nerve in his face that moved
this cheek Sophie is even after he got
plastic surgery he looked good he still
had dead movement in his cheek then look
at the age of 20 lucky I got a stroke so
we don't know we weren't there I want to
congratulate George congratulate the UFC
I'm being [ __ ] creative and finally
you know making a car I mean it was just
a great idea all around and everybody
enjoyed themselves
it wasn't the ending we expected but
again you've never seen a bookie with a
part-time job Nate Diaz was the underdog
and if you saw people like I told my
wife looking to listen to the garden
they're all yelling Diaz the as there is
everybody their mother bet Diaz so it's
just the way life works out I hope they
do it back I may run it back but listen
man whatever point in your life you're
on you may be a little frustrated get
that notebook out I've said it once I'll
tell you 20 [ __ ] times this [ __ ]
doesn't happen overnight
I wish it did I wish that you just did
something a few times and you got good
at it it takes time and even one you
should get there you gotta figure out
what the [ __ ] you're gonna do it that's
what people never really understand
everybody wants to get to that place but
then they get to that place and they
really don't know what to do and I'm
guilty it is still weird none of us know
what to do when we get kicked in the
stomach 15 times and you figure it out
Mars Duvall figured it out and this is a
lesson for this is not about gambling or
this is not about who's tough who hit
harder or you know who's making a
comeback there's nothing I'm trying to
read between the lines here and show you
guys I wish that you read between the
lines on this fight even as preparation
for Diaz everything where the DA's got
hurt or you couldn't run the last four
weeks Mazda vawa's precision
his kick
for position and it's something that you
look at and you whatever you do in your
life you're like one is my life you know
one of the piece is gonna fall together
while I'm sorry to tell you something
the pieces never fall together when was
the last time you bought a puzzle that
was built you ever bought a puzzle that
was built no so why we think the beats
kind of fall together you have to put
the pieces together I guarantee you that
once you put the pieces together of your
life it's a different feeling
look at my he's a different man it's a
different man when you look at look at
the old him what happened he do drugs
that he do steroids we know he looked
within himself and he found the answer
to all his [ __ ] dilemmas and he
applied himself and that's what we talk
about here on the church doesn't happen
overnight man the stars have to be
aligned yes I agree with you there
you got me on that argument but you have
to be prepared for the Stars to be
aligned and you have to look at that
fight like that that's a big lesson for
all of us that have been frustrated then
there you go he was frustrated he was a
50/50 fighter he didn't know what was
gonna happen when he got into a fight
all he knew was that he was tough and he
knew what a hand himself but that's not
enough sometimes that's not enough this
is where your mind comes in and you tap
into your mind and your mind don't set
the gameplan for you you know Leah's
always said you're very calculating
every move has to be calculated or if
not you're gonna get if you watch Derek
Lewis's fight the first chick he threw
he didn't have to throw it and what
happened he almost got his [ __ ] leg
twisted don't throw I have to work that
lesson is don't throw 50% if you're not
gonna go on you percent don't throw it
don't throw it that day no another
lesson Derrick Lewis when he threw his
foot up like a big piece of steak him
and the guy grabbed it and tried to vote
off whatever his [ __ ] name Dracula's
cousin tried to [ __ ] twist his ankle
and all that [ __ ] that that's what
happens when you're going to something
Africa
so you learn two things watching that
fight last night I hope that you fought
to enjoyed it and I hope that it all
worked out for you I'm saying oh this is
on the same similar note what do you
think I just don't I don't know how you
feel about him but what did you think
about Kevin Lee switching to a great
head coach and change making a change
look at okay I don't know I didn't even
think about [ __ ] Kevin Lee I wasn't
even thinking about Kevin later beyond
saying that poor kid he fought he's
still in Juke left for Kent there's
nothing to talk about okay
yeah there's no lesson then learn he
sweats big [ __ ] deal he lost last
three fights which time he did something
you know I can kudos for switching but
you know okay
he's that poor [ __ ] kid out there to
carry him out this [ __ ] head was a
little man bun what a [ __ ] shame the
world man bothered like that
unbelievable what a [ __ ] nightmare
that book did that poor bastard now
there's someone I want to tell you guys
about a story that didn't bother me at
all not whatsoever but it's just really
weird how life changes that the week put
that I went to Jersey I got a call from
a dear dear friend of mine 40 year
friend
he called me with a big big problem he
had a bad situation going on his life
and he needed a big fare from me and I
told him I'd look into it and I hung up
the phone I made a few phone calls from
him and Jersey guy Jersey guy grew up
with I love them with all my heart
you know and that night at dinner I ran
it past my wife and she couldn't believe
it but I explained to her that it was
something I had to do you know this kid
had been friends with me since maybe the
summer of 78 and we got we navigated to
one another and it was weird because him
and I uh we hung out a group of friends
but him a night and me not him in the
eye
gravitated to one another because of our
love of psychedelic drugs crazy [ __ ] so
we were freshmen we would go out with
these guys we would smoke pot and we
would tell the other six guys that we
were just smoking pot but him and I
already droppin acid but he had older
brothers and he didn't want his brothers
to find out he was doing acid so it was
just him a nice secret and this went on
for a year you know this one on for
[ __ ] years
I'm gonna hide tripping at parties and
he would go talk to chicks and I would
go talk to guys check so whoever and
every 15 minutes we just look at each
other and smile and when one day what he
was a wrestler in high school and one
half the one he was about to wrestle and
I had some of that THC crystal an angel
dust and I asked him if he wanted to do
a line in the afternoon and he was like
yeah and he goes holy [ __ ]
I got a wrestling meet at 4:30 and he
was so high during the mess wrestling
meet that he actually bit the kid and he
got disqualified you know when we were
juniors in high school you gotta pass
the paperwork forward you know I'm
saying like have you sit in the back
right you like pass the task forward and
I would get his test and I'd erase his
answers and he would get like a [ __ ]
70 and he'd be furious because he was
[ __ ] really smart I wouldn't [ __ ] up
- Havanese I studied I did the notes Oh
somebody erase and then he went to the
teacher one day like somebody's erasing
my answers I think it's you you [ __ ] and
the teachers like why would I erase your
answers and all this [ __ ] this one out
for years we graduated high school
together we were very tight in high
school and this guy went to a
prestigious college you know and during
my homeless era my whole fucked-up era
in 84 85 he was my only salvation he was
going to college but he was selling coke
in college so he made me his partner
because he couldn't go to places to get
okay like because I could speak Spanish
so he made me his part and we made some
great money together we ended up beat
the dealer we'd be the new dealers and
then but he was there with me when I was
homeless he was one of those guys that
was always my friend he was one of the
few people that when I was homeless and
I was really upset I would be crying in
his car one day by just breaking down
the daytime in his car going when is my
life gonna change you know what is this
command and one that you know it was
like a [ __ ] a curse on me and he was
the only ray of hope I mean that listen
I had dear dear dear friends growing up
in the or serve their purpose for
different things as their friendship but
this guy said me this God would bring me
money to a hotel he knew more about me
than most people nor was going on you
know when I was sleeping in the park he
asked me 10 times to just sleep on his
back in his garage he said you don't
need to sleep at the park
you know I'll sleep downstairs my mother
won't say that but now we go you know
what with two good friends you know I
don't want us to get into that situation
I'll be fine and he finally gave me a
blanket the one night he came to the
park and brought me a blanket I mean
there was just different things and we
were always good friends and it was
always a fifty-fifty willis but from
8485 he really helped me out of pocket a
bunch of tonics and before I left in 85
I got a credit card and I took him
shopping
trust me I didn't pay for anything it
was a stolen credit card
but I wasn't sued sneakers jewelry alone
more jewelry a TV for his room and at
that time in 1985 he was so [ __ ]
slick he had two speakers in his room
with a stereo and whenever you went to
his house and he put the stereo and you
could tell he won't speak that wasn't
working the other speak that was close
to the closet
come on we were 21 years old one there
he took me to that speaker and he took
the little off that cover off the
speaker live to speak there was 24
inches whatever two feet he had a foot a
rubber band money and heat rubber band
was like ten thousand dollars and listen
if you know any story about me you know
I robbed everybody I never even thought
about robbing him especially the day he
took that off
he knew the position I was in and he
knew what I could do he had seen me in
action and he showed me that and that
was I can never break his trust after
that but it was really went to a
prestigious college you got a degree in
engineering he was a brilliant guy and
today he lives and basically a shack
behind the house I think it barely has
heat
he has three or four teeth missing he
doesn't have a job he just says he just
does hard jobs from time to time he
collects unemployment and time to time
he sells an envelope you know he sells a
little coke to this guy of that guy and
that's how he makes ends meet he I mean
he lives how I thought how it's like we
it's like we switch lives it's like
somewhere along the line we switch live
like he ended up being who I was
supposed to become and love becoming who
he was supposed to become you know he
was a smart guy he was on the smartest
guys that I hung out with on paper he
was [ __ ] really smart like he was
just engineer type smart I say Dee blew
the [ __ ] scores off the roof he hits
College is off to him and he picked the
school and he went he got a degree and
we all grew up during that cocaine
epidemic and you know I wasn't there for
a long time
I went back in 91 he was still in the
[ __ ] game and telling me this and
that and I'm not there I'm not there so
I'm not watching he could tell me
whatever the [ __ ] he wanted to I would
believe him he's my brother and then I
went back in 93 and again we hung out
you know endlessly I mean he picked me
up five nights a week
just to go into the city to get weed I
mean he was dropping me off I don't know
how many times I was waiting for a bus
on Kennedy Boulevard he'd swing by and
give me a ride into the city and we got
pulled over one night and have a license
and he lied he told he gave him my lime
and it's just been a friendship that
never [ __ ] ended but the last ten
years of his life of his life have been
a nightmare lost his dad he got a rest
of the other probation you know he's
never been married he's never had any
children and you know when I was in that
rocket ship at night in nine eighty
three I would think about my future at
night and think about me in a little
apartment you know a little smaller than
this office and I would see me with like
a TV and just a couple of bad pants and
a couple t-shirts all dirty and that's
how I was gonna end up am i I accepted
that you know I accepted that in early
aids that if I even live to 50 or 55
that I would just be making it I would
be on disability or faking it somewhere
or just sad or not going to work I'd
just be one of those guys like well it
did that upset you were you okay with it
when I was at that age yeah when you
were thinking about this I came to like
turn I was an idiot
I had no college no high school
education my chances are going to
college was slim and none
I couldn't stop putting this white
powder in my nose and I had no family
I had nothing to home for me I couldn't
even [ __ ] pay for breakfast how was I
gonna pay for an apartment so I just
thought about my life
I just saw myself and a rent subsidized
men's home you know with a little corner
and Aloha plate and maybe a
black-and-white TV and then tonight I
would read books and not accept my fate
I mean that's what happens to people
when you're uneducated and you have no
and you're addicted to drugs over your
life I mean I saw that picture when I
was 21 years old I saw my future like
that so when he called me with this mess
II was in you know I called a few
friends that reached out to a few
friends you know obviously it cost me
something which I did not mind because
of all these things that happen but I
also had to call him and talk to him a
little bit and explain to him that I'm
his brother and I love him I'll have to
anything in the world for him but he's
55 years old and he's got a bail out of
this world with something you know I
told him you just can't leave this world
without doing something you were meant
to be a [ __ ] engineer you got out
tremendous college degree you know the
felonies [ __ ] you up but I know you I
know you said you were kid you've always
figured a way out of this it was a tough
it was a tough talk for me to have with
him because he's one of my few friends
that he's really sensitive right now
like he's on the point in his life where
he's by himself
even like his brothers turned their
backs on him one of the brothers came to
one of my shows I manic city kind of
yelled at me for still being his friend
and I'm not helping them you know and
and I probably I can't turn my back on I
mean he was there for me I had a really
weird time in my life when I really
needed somebody you know so I called him
up I had a real sensitive on the light
side talk with him
I told him that I could help him you
know if he got into a mess again
but the favors article and firm on this
one were huge like I had to really get
myself on my hands and knees oh the tool
my friends to do this favor for me for
him and after we had our talk he thanked
me we'll eat when everything was taken
care of he thanked me like a man like we
we do we called me explain what he did
and what steps he took to take care of
the situation
and I was happy I was really content
that I told my wife that it's fine you
know he's never gonna get himself in
this situation again and that uh you
know we're cool you know and then I got
the thinking about it and I got to
thinking about all the friends from
Timmy - Roger - ferny Glynn County
there's a lot of guys that won't talk to
me anymore but there's a lot of guys I
still have that were there since day one
when there was no comedy career so they
have every reason to be my friend now
they have every reason to call for free
tickets they have every reason to
exploit me at every [ __ ] level
because when I wasn't even thinking
about Charlie they they had my back you
know from sitting area they and I'm
thinking about this situation with my
body and how he got himself into this
mess you know I'm lucky that I have a
friend and it's a cop and I have a
couple friends of the cops in Jersey but
this particular one he's been a friend
for a while and not that type of friend
that I could help call them for a favor
and then I was happy - everything bailed
out but then I thought about something
but I thought about why the real reason
was that I helped this kid out this time
and I've helped them the last 20 times
and the real real reason which I never
told anybody till the other night and it
hit me on that [ __ ] day uh
mid-october 79 I was doing everything I
was doing
mescaline I was smoking [ __ ] THC
crystal I was snorting THC crystal I was
drinking mallow I was never a big
drinker
but I had always sworn off drugs like I
always sworn off cocaine and heroin and
pills they just were not gonna be in my
drug whatever I was very content with
the marijuana in the acid I was very
content at the age of 15 the mother
wanted acid I was gonna say that's still
pretty young but I was I I liked the
relationship I had with my friends I
enjoyed everything about those drugs I
had grown up I'd seen a lot of heroin in
New York as a kid I didn't like what it
did to people especially to friends of
my moms that I saw a girl [ __ ] astray
and I had definitely seen the results of
cocaine being at the bar you know and I
didn't know the full blast but I didn't
I knew I didn't want to do any of those
drugs you know but again we're gonna go
I told you guys a long time ago that
there's a hundred stories I could tell
you but there's a hundred that I can't
tell you well for me to dip into this
[ __ ] book in this one man Sean
everything had been raining a lot lately
and I thought about something that I've
never really repeated about mid-october
79 if you know anything about where I
lived in North Bergen and given that
Terrace I had an attic then I had a
second floor and then I had the first
floor which had the living room its
kitchen and the dining area and in the
backyard you could go out to the yard
then if you walked down the steps you
had a garage there was a garage and
additional closet space a bathroom no
shower
the pisser in a sink and a wash and a
dryer but then there was another set
upstairs
I've set a set of stairs that went down
another level and if he opened up that
door there was a refrigerator filled
with beer and there was a [ __ ] bar
like a little three-seat stool bar and
my mother had the bar stocked and there
was a record player down there though
though the walls had a couple of holes
them from our karate days when we go
flying through the air down there and it
was paneling it was paneled around the
cinder block and then it had a paneling
around the hot water and in the tank and
there was a room in there there's a
fucked-up story and when you went behind
into that room it was again half the
size of the office and let's say the
hot-water heater was right there if you
weren't behind the hot-water heater away
there was like a latch I you know I was
down there playing around there was like
a latch that you haven't like pick up
this thing and kind of turn it like a
paint can you know you pick up a paint
can and it has that [ __ ] ball with it
well think if you had to turn something
like that and it was kind of sensitive
but you had to turn it real slowly and
if you turned it it would open up and a
piece would come out like something that
yeah just your body could fit in like a
manhole so a circular there was like
circular and you had a church whistling
around and it was covered with them with
a piece of metal damn and if you took
that up and you circle to go to the
sewer you went down into the street go
into the street it was [ __ ] scary I
had looked in there one time and I heard
noises oh Jesus I closed that
[ __ ] up and I put and that was
it so in that corner was just the hot
water either that we used to be messed
up for all those tools and that's it I
don't know what happened October 79
something made me go downstairs
and I'm lying to you guys maybe August a
Sunday night something made me I'm lying
again maybe July of 7-9
sup Mamie I just had a refresh my memory
something made me girl on stairs and I
went out seven time I opened them to
think I thought the door was a little
open like an inch like a wisest [ __ ]
these two kids it was like two panels
they yell to the small room to the small
room found went down the stairs opened
up the door and notice that two panels
one of them was open and when I opened
up the panel's I went inside and there
was a coffee bean bag like a bale well
it was filled with weed Oh share that a
little top piece off the top and I went
upstairs and I didn't say nothin or body
at that time I was getting wheat and
this guy named Joe he was my main dealer
Joe I would call Joe and I would buy her
out 75 bucks I'll sell him for like 50
and sell for a hundred and make 50 bucks
off him and he give me a ride uptown he
was a good guy so I took this weed and I
rolled it up and I smoked it with some
my friend and the weed was tremendous
and the guy's name was Joe and that gave
him to Joe he's like Wade you get that
weed from that weeds better than mine so
I got a whole [ __ ] tank at home Jesus
filled with this [ __ ] so I went back and
just kept taking it and I came home one
day and this and two guys they would
have checked it may remembered me and
they hugged me and [ __ ] and they're
talking to my mother and I hugged them
and now we haven't seen each other long
I forget what their names are guys that
I really do but it was a bigger Cuban
guy a skinnier Cuban guy and I'm the
skinnier Cuban guy's wife and I had
known him I every time I went to Miami
there were friends of my uncle Rodolfo
my godfather
so I would see them in Miami now they're
in my living room when I'm talking to
him and they telling me how they're
staying up there now you know I didn't
figure out at the time so I go
downstairs a couple days later it's a
different batch of weed they had taken
the old batch and I kept going
downstairs and taking a little bit and
selling it to Joe and sell it to my
friends and I was just making spare
money and one day my mom actually pulled
me over as I talk to you in private
have you been snooping around down there
like Oh what are you talking about she
wasn't even going down there taking
marijuana out of those bales I don't
know
and she goes cuz the guy called you at
anyone oh no I thought taken out like a
half ounce are you did you take it out
of there I felt heartbroken I didn't
know I want my mother to know I did
drugs or any point so I lied to us and
no she goes I wonder what the [ __ ] is
going on let this time my mother had to
know I had sticky fingers you know I had
caused a lot of problems one and there
was just too many suspicious [ __ ]
things you know thing of the
disappearing things were moving you know
so I said you know what out of respect
to my mom I'm not gonna touch that thing
no more but I got sick I ended up
getting that the hair quad paraquat in
the corn to the hospital the 28th from
the wind eh no or no I don't know okay I
don't know whose weed it was that I got
the quad from so I I played off the
weeds for a few weeks I got out of the
[ __ ] house boil it up the way that
good acid immediately I was a young kid
but I was stupid [ __ ] September 28 79 I
got out of the hospital there's a a
big-time fight I think we checked it
before Mohammed Holloway against
somebody I don't [ __ ] know I hope you
feel weeks after that I gonna hike up
let me know what stairs to see if
there's any weed downstairs I go
downstairs I don't want the little
cabinet and there's two rats so I open
up the one Bell sure enough it's weed I
take a little bud a couple little buds
like maybe an eighth and I figure I'm
gonna take Nathan both bales don't never
know I want to help him up the other
bail it wasn't weed it was cold I'd
never done coke before I know what it
did to people I didn't know exactly
I knew it made people talk a lot and I
knew it made people make weird faces
cuz I knew it made people make little
[ __ ] gestures with that [ __ ]
filthy little hands
so I said what do I do
so I said you know what we'll take a
little bit and put it in the container
and put it upstairs and just save it
just see if somebody wants to buy them
or that so that night I took up a little
bit from it and I put it in a little
room for that's what it was 79 everybody
had a little room for knowing what I
know now I probably took a gram and I
probably took three tenths or four
tenths of a gram for the balloon for and
gave it to a friend of mine and said let
me know what you think it's like wow
there's in those days to give something
just but somebody gave me a joint was
big - somebody give you cocaine and
everybody wanted cocaine those days and
here I had it my [ __ ] garage
interesting how strong it was
yes I gave it to my buddy what tell me
what do you think walking the next day
is like dog that [ __ ] is [ __ ] rocket
fuel you gotta get me more but I knew
the value of it and then want to get my
mother in trouble so I thought I
couldn't get it no more and I took the
rest of it and put it in like a jacket
and it stayed that and I figured I was
gonna wait for another friend of mine
and tell me that he did it and I was
given whatever I had left you know
so come Halloween Day 1979 I you know
the night before like the night before
we already made a plan way and nobody's
gonna school tomorrow but playing hooky
I'm gonna cut out of you win I'm like
yeah man cuz you were trick-or-treating
a lot yeah treat at all and like I think
I didn't wear a costume a dress well I
think you're doing a C to get well
[ __ ] costume I think that woman that
year I went to a chick Halloween party
but I think that main lubes we're just
talking about this at distress Factory
in New Jersey I mean the villa was
talking about it that me villo and my
friend lubes dressed up my ghosts and we
all took acid and we all just stand each
other along
and we could go to a Halloween party
that was probably the last time I
dressed up change that yeah like a ghost
and I think I dressed up again when I
was three years later in Colorado like
an abortion but we ain't acquaintances I
passed out and we never made that house
I woke up with a hangover on my neck and
long underwear [ __ ] hilarious but but
to get back to it so the night before
Halloween so many nice so night before
Halloween something like me and my
buddies go [ __ ] we'll play hooky
tomorrow okay that morning when I woke
up I took a shower got dressed my god
I'm little bit my buddies I had some
weed and I had some mescaline and I go
wait a second maybe I should bring this
coke let go
I'll bring the coke with me I'm not
gonna do it you know but I'll give it to
somebody some chick whatever now give me
some coke and [ __ ] so I took the coke
with me I took the bus up to high school
we met at wizards where we used to meet
a pinball place called Wizards from
stair and we were home on our way the
Albertson's by Hudson County Park - Rob
- Rob booze from Albertsons because
Albert's is there's no security
so we just go in there and each of us
would takes up and run out and run
inside some County Park with booze and
Jonathan they couldn't chase us under
you're half a kid in a pinball place so
when you're stealing liquor so we're at
a pinball Plato's next to hatchway is
the deli in those days they live the
pinball place ash ways and then a liquor
store on the corner and the kid Joey she
own used to hang out that liquor store
all the time his friends with the owner
the guy knew like all we had to do was
stand in front of the [ __ ] like a
store he knew we were aliens and he knew
we would smash his [ __ ] windows so he
wasn't there not if we got somebody
going to him he would sell us the booze
okay so we're walking paths we're at
wizards and we go [ __ ] we're not
gonna we can't find anybody attend the
buyers booze so let's go to Hudson
County Park while we pay for booze
just robbed the [ __ ] hobbits in some
he runs a park if you can damn it and
we'll smoke these wheels lube all I can
handle I got 25 hour bag of weed and we
rolled it up too late before like 32
joints and you know we'd started ten and
we'd go up till 3:00 in the afternoon so
we're walking the pods in County Park
and also over here like brakes yeah and
we turn around and fifty yards unless is
a beer truck across the street from that
like a store Albertsons the name
sometimes he would park in front of the
liquor store for some reason he parked
in from the bank across the street from
the liquor store and we looked at him
there was one single guy he's walking
across the street like whistling it's a
beautiful thing to be alive we [ __ ]
dash across the street and not on the
side that's to him yeah the backside
other side and you go on the other side
slide open the [ __ ] door
and we'd take a case of something
heineken michelob whatever and we
[ __ ] start running down the [ __ ]
Hill and the guy's like hey come back
and we start to little cases and you
know like other four or five of us I
think we lost three cases the guys
chasing this down the [ __ ] hill and
we ran down to like the street called
probably and then my buddy said the one
that got into the trumpet three weeks
ago a month ago said to me my mother's
getting a head done today in certain day
let's go to my house
so he went back to his house we put the
beers in the refrigerator we took the
other beers and put them in a bucket
with ice and we smoked pot in his yard
for a little while we got my son's cocoa
we loved it was like maybe six of us at
this point two other guys came home and
we had I never forget we had a case of
courts and from one of the guys robbed a
bottle of vodka from his mother's house
and everybody was Italian in that
neighborhood saw him everybody had
sambuca so my buddy whose house it was
that I did all the acid with like that
day we're in the basement listening to
music
you don't get high but the other four
guys didn't know that him and I wanna
ask are you also an asset that day we
were on acid we were drinking it was
smoking dope it's 11:00 in the morning
again I will listen to Led Zeppelin
listened we were young at Ted Nugent
this is way before Pink Floyd the wall
this is like Aerosmith days Ted Nugent
and was sitting there and next thing you
know he says to me that he's gonna go
upstairs and make vodka and sambuca like
peppermint schnapps somebody we also
have bishops function so we're gonna
make vodka and sambuca and there's a
name for that like frozen something I
don't know I'm not up all the [ __ ]
bartender names [ __ ] like this so he
goes let's go upstairs and let's shave
ice and let's make these sambuca or
these peppermint schnapps vodka drinks
so I said okay so they're all downstairs
you know I don't know how many kids are
exactly there you know but me and him go
upstairs alone this kid like I said at
the time he was an honor student but he
was crazy like me he wasn't uh you know
I was Lou genex and it was just me and
him it was our little secret and the
real reason why I helped him out and I
always help him out is because of this
I've never told my buddies while we were
in that kitchen I looked at him and I
owe ya I gotta show you something but I
wanted my pocket and I took out the
aluminum for and he goes what is that
cocaine I think those where'd you get it
and I never liked the way I got it from
downstairs in my mother's basement I go
but I gave some to such as such he told
me it's rock a few what do you think now
in my heart I didn't really want to do
it
but if he called my bluff out of it
stuck so he goes [ __ ] it let's do it so
I opened up the other won't fall Oh
empty that what was on that thing we cut
up into four lines we'd still alive we
looked at each other for like four or
five minutes then we do another line a
piece and then whatever was left we
sprinkled on the drinks we drank that we
never told nobody nothing but the reason
why that kid didn't grow up to his
potential was because I game that line
of code that day and I could never
forget that and I can never forgive
myself for that and when that thought
came to me Thursday night because this
came to me Thursday like I'd been I went
to a stress factory last week the
situation that the cops is handled by
Friday and he had gone to check my
Monday I spoke to him on Tuesday for two
days whatever went down had to eat away
at me but Thursday after the [ __ ]
trick-or-treating and the walking and
the Halloween parade that night when I
got home that night I looked at my wife
my uncle I tell you something do you
really want me to tell you why I bailed
this kidnap I've never told me but it is
I go because I was the first person who
ever get back kicked okay me and hit the
cocaine together Halloween 1979 if I
wouldn't have given him that coat his
life would have been completely
different maybe my life would have been
completely different because I would
have never done it I don't know if I
would have done I don't know I mean part
of you has to realize that like you said
at the beginning that you guys grew up
through the cocaine epidemic so you
could be right but I mean at the least
50/50 we were we were 50 miles away
I could look you in the eye and tell you
that if you want me to candy-coat him
for ya you know man like it can't be
called it but I'm not gonna candy
totally okay we were fifty miles away
from the Holland
we shouldn't even a thought about doing
cocaine though we were 19 and by that
time we were to look at each other and
said it's too late we ain't doing that
junk look what's happening around this
but we didn't I should have never taken
that coat and I should have never
brought it to that kids house that day
so after I told my wife this I told my
wife this and she looked at me she was
at now I knew I got up like a man I went
in my office and I call them like I
thought be about so I just want you to
know something and this is how I feel I
feel that he went to this College you
did all these great things but it was
the poison I gave you in 1979 that led
you astray cuz he told me when I spoke
to him on Tuesday that he had got a
little [ __ ] up again for a few weeks
so he went off track
you know this has been going on you know
I'm being him with the same person until
I quit 12 years ago so Jim said I'm
trying to say to you
I've always had that guilt about that
kid I've robbed people I've done a lot
of bad stupid [ __ ] but that has always
eaten me alive that I gave that kid his
first line of coke his first two or
three lines of code and after that we
just fell in line like after that there
was no stopping us within three months I
had moved me and him leading the
quaalude we had acquaintance and the
coldest night of [ __ ] January I went
to a party owner at Hudson County Park
and I went to a Chinese restaurant you
know that opened up a door by that time
we were already [ __ ] snorted acident
was creeping away and cocaine was coming
in and yeah hey listen maybe I'm be
you're right Lee
and he even said he goes I don't look at
it that way I was like listen who knows
who knows but maybe those two years
maybe if we nearly muscled out for two
years we would have kept doing acid and
everybody else for the guy [ __ ] up we
would have seen the results of other
people getting [ __ ] up when we
wouldn't have done what he done as
possible I mean I know it's not possible
but this is the question I always ask
myself like if you could go back and
redo it and like have to live your life
all over again and change that what do
you do it no I would have never taken
that cup but you live you could what I'm
saying if you had the choice be like
okay you can either keep going or go
back and switch it but then you have to
live your life all over again I don't
know I don't welcome all I'm saying is
that it was a bad move by me 40 years
ago this Halloween and I wouldn't I got
through half of the [ __ ] I went through
and he wouldn't be in the position he
was in
today if we wouldn't have [ __ ] done
this Fran and I have to look at it from
that perspective I really do I really
have always felt that and after he got
in trouble like the first time where the
cops kicked his door down I was always
welcome at his house after the concert
the cops kicked this door now leaded The
Longest Yard and in the interviews for
the local papers that said by the time
he wouldn't invite me in this house
anymore I think his mother put it
together and his father put it together
and I think his mother still knows that
we're friends but she put together that
maybe because he hung out with me at an
early age he got into the trouble he did
because when I gave my interview in 2004
I was very candid I was very honest
about my drug use and stuff and they put
it on paper I didn't mention any names
but you know your sons with this kid
five [ __ ] nights a week
one night I put coconut on the house I
hit it and I woke her up and 4:00 in the
morning and told her that left my wallet
in his bedroom and I wanted his bedroom
and took the coke out of the closet
because he was in the city every
we put a Terrell Ronald out so you know
these are the stories I tell people that
live with him I'm ashamed of I am he had
the potential do anything he wanted in
this [ __ ] life anything he [ __ ] won
in this life do I get up in the morning
and cry no do I go to see a psychiatrist
about it no I feel the same thing you
feel part of me feels that eventually we
both would handle that we would handle
up that's the way faith is but in my
little paranoid responsible mind I'm
responsible for that kid and I love him
dearly
like I love him dearly he's my brother
I'll never let him starve I'll never let
anything bad happened to him because he
put up he'd hurt he took he took he
never took a beating for me but he took
a lot of he had beans because of me and
he would tell everybody go [ __ ]
themselves so this is the story of my
life this is Who I am today
speaking of which yesterday November's
always been a weird [ __ ] one to me
guys like November's one of those months
that one of my great friends died
November yes
Sunday yesterday the third it's 12 years
she's been dead you know was Rick Ramos
his birthday yesterday it was my mother
died this year November 8th to be the
40th anniversary of my mother's debt I
got arrested this month in 87 I quit
cocaine November in 19 in 2007 I'm
coming up on 12 years no coke a lot of
different things happen to me my I was
initiated into Santeria and November
November is a pretty big month for me
and yesterday morning I woke up I knew
Marilyn had died he the third or fourth
or the fifth
I just had a weight that popped up on
Facebook but she's Rick Ramos his
birthday and I knew the anniversary but
this morning Sunday morning when I woke
up I woke up about 8:00 and I was
pistons and I was I was pissing I
immediately thought of Marilyn and I
swear to god guys I wanted and got
coffee you know had breakfast the family
the girls went to church I have to take
a class on Sundays on screenwriting and
I think 20 minutes after my wives left
after my wife and the baby left the
phone rang and it was Rick I know happy
birthday I was just about to call you I
was just thinking of my mouth I know
this is the day it was 12 years and me
and where he spoke a little bit we spoke
about Apocalypse Now I'm he was there no
8:30 waits for me like a [ __ ] idiot
that's why I love him but you know I
talk a lot about Ralphie I'm here we
touch on Brody a lot I never really
talked to you guys about Marilyn
Martinez uh I met Marilyn Martinez in 96
in Los Angeles the Latino that fester
was doing a showcase and they said that
if I could get myself down a they would
put me up at two nights and give me a
cons for padilla if i came down and
showcase to be in problem
so I ride rode on e rot long I had to do
a trip he was a photographer so thank
God to run long I the Seattle Robin wall
I told my love of my situation he goes
[ __ ] I gotta go now
anyway I'll Drive you because we'll just
drive and split the gas I go fine and we
drove to LA and I went to the improv and
I ate a bag of dicks for the showcase
you know I mean there's one thing
driving ten minutes in in dying
never mind driving eighteen hours to die
a slow death but it was also a Monday
night they told me to go with the Laugh
Factory and Latino me they said if you
go over then tell me you're from out of
town
they'll put you up and I went over there
the place was sold out the lineup was
[ __ ] pure death
Pablo Francisco Carlos Mencia George
Lopez I mean it was [ __ ] just dirty
[ __ ] tremendous show I got there in
time and I asked a kid if I could go up
and he goes yeah you go up next in fact
over wait for you we sell apart six
minutes and I walk up there died another
slug that but I made a couple people I
have a little people I made a laugh was
just chubby check in the back
I was no stage two minutes and the girl
came right up to me and she's like I
know you
you're from Denver I had people talk to
me about you you used to work in Boulder
and I go yeah and she goes my name is
Marilyn Martinez and I gave hug and she
black crap husband it was a sweetheart
of a man and we went outside and she
filled me in on LA and at the Latino
scene was moving and this and this and
this that she gave me a number
and the next day I got up from the hotel
and with the last $20 I had I think I
took a cab over to Silver Lake and she
introduced me to Joe Garcia and a bunch
other comics and she gave me numbers to
call once I came back to LA and she said
you should stay you know yeah I got a
spare bedroom after I ate there I got
the meter she's like just stay you know
I'm like I can't I got a girl fill up
and see out on my probation I gotta go
back up there bla bla bla bla bla bla
but I called her every week from Seattle
you know I kept in touch with her for
like 6 or 7 months and then once Doug
Stanhope came up then told me to move I
called her and I said what do you think
that she was now is the perfect time and
I came down and she introduced me to the
guy that was doing Latino night at the
store and he was doing Latino Nydia at
The Improv I forget what his name is god
bless his soul he was a good dude and
then Latino night The Laugh Factory was
up so she pretty much filled me in I'm
what to do she asked me where I was
gonna go on Monday night if I had a
place to stay and I had a girlfriend
and I said yes she does won't make she
go to the store and I'm not gonna go
down there tonight but I'll see you
there during a week you have to get to
this floor just from the time she saw
him to get offstage she was one of those
people that came up to me and sent his
mitts he seen here and I'm like Nam it's
he hasn't seen me so it was just I kept
in touch when I moved back and then when
I came to Hawaii I called her and we
became friends and she was a big-time
regular at the storm it's he loved her
that was Mitzi's girl
it's he loved because she was dirty she
was fat she was brash you know a whole
[ __ ] thing so after I became you know
even before that I think she talked to
Mitzi about me and Mitzi
listen Tara a little bit so it was like
heroin Andy Griffith and we just became
dear friends and then she introduced me
to refrain most oh maybe 2000 and maybe
had enough Rick first moody he was a kid
and we became friends and I learned a
lot from her family because she had been
here for that long you know she had been
here already for like 15 years she was
regular to store like a 94 or something
like that
and we became dear friends and it was
just amazing she was friends of Ralphie
y'all saw me walk three fat [ __ ] so we
loved each other and they were I still
when the girl on the road with her
Corpus Christi I flew and her and her
husband drove and when I went to their
room the next day then they came up with
up one of those nine-foot coolers right
yeah and they had everything in their
sandwich meat peanuts yogurt
they were happy ition on the road I mean
we were both getting like maybe $750 you
know the plane think it was maybe two I
just didn't want to drive to 24 hours
you know but I still number coming up
one night going night then looking free
downstairs if they got pay yet oh yeah
he paid me she was did he give you an
envelope over cocaine I don't know he
goes here take mine and she gave me them
filled with [ __ ] coke and I went down
and got more coke Marilyn was uh one of
us
Marilyn was really well-respected at the
store you know she was just starting to
bust out you know like she had a little
successor Paul Rodriguez and then she
did the Divas of comedy and then she did
something else with Showtime and she was
getting love she was opening up for Paul
and she had a stomach ain't one that
that didn't go away for two days she
went to the doctor and they told her she
had cancer we went down there and saw it
had spread [ __ ] like wildfire already
you know and then when I got down there
at the story - a man gone to the
bathroom for weeks after the first week
you gotta be but we're all very scared
of doctors and we think these things are
gonna pass as hyper should I do
and it was too late you know she got
diagnosed in April they did all this
surgery to her all these surgeries she
stayed in the hospital till probably
July and then after that I was in and
out like he would talk to her one day at
the house the next day you were talking
to her at the hospital then the next day
they'd move her to another hospital
because they specialized in that cancer
in [ __ ] Carson so we couldn't get to
go see her but then she finally came
home and on the Sunday they had a big
thing for her house and I went over
there they put her bed
they had it with a special bread in the
living room and when I walked in the
room she had lost 70 pounds you know and
I gave her a hug and a kiss we talked
and we ate I play with the cats I talked
to her husband Dave and it was a small
window that her and I had and I went
over to one i sat I go how you feeling
and she knows she was dying you could
see in her eyes that she was
and she said to me that if she was very
Catholic but she was very dirty on stage
and I'm one day my wife telling me that
how come every time she calls it she's
gotta answer the phone [ __ ] like
my wife won't answer phone like hello
and she go [ __ ]
she's very dirty remember that day she
said to me that if she got to survive
cancer that shooting never do a dirty
joke again because God didn't wanna do
dirty material now I'm sitting there
this whole time I'm listening tour and I
know she's under some type of drugs you
know like they have a pain like I were
talking back and forth about cancer and
I mean what treatment she has if she
gets out of this patch he's got one
surgery left and she looks up at me
we're talking about whether we're
talking about but it wasn't what came
out of her words what Kim wasn't what
you know we were toiling if we were
talking about sports she just stopped
and she looked me straight in the face
like nobody ever has and she just by the
way God wants you to stop don't go and
dog if you know anything about me if
anybody ever said that to me I would
laugh in their face but the way her eyes
were looking at me the way her eyes were
looking at me I knew she wasn't [ __ ]
around but just standing to me and the
feeling went through my eyes and then to
my stomach and I'm like anybody else I
were told to go [ __ ] yourself and I just
said uh okay and that was a Sunday
and I think I did coke like that night
let's go up that line like it was weird
out of this whole situation went down
but it started with her it started with
her her believe like she just stopped
she does you guys stop them though God
wants you to stop don't go Joey you have
a career you have a great girlfriend you
have to stop but I looked on I said I
know which usually I would have told you
go [ __ ] yourself mind your business
what do you know how much coke I'm doing
you know I was in denial like any other
addict you know
and I said you're right I think that
night I got my maybe the night after
that I got high and then I had that
meeting for that movie the woman they
said you knew couldn't yeah it was
around that time or maybe I'm lying here
what happened was I had a benefit in New
Jersey one on Friday night for the
Hoboken Police Department and one on
Saturday for the North Bergen basketball
know someone on the Friday wasn't
Hoboken the one on Saturday was a North
Bergen I got high like that Sunday and
Monday and then something wasn't right
something wasn't right and I may have
gotten too high that Thursday but I
couldn't wait to get on the plane to get
I like maybe I didn't get high that
Thursday I didn't and I touched base in
New York and I had my own hotel room I
had a great hotel room in Fort Lee and I
was close to a friend of mind that she
could always get go I grew up with her I
talked to her and her husband all the
time and in fact she was telling me call
me when you're ready and I'll bring
something hola I have the cash I'll pull
it up read it and element something just
wasn't right that Friday night even get
high that's Saturn of them to get high
and that's Sunday when I landed was I
found out that she died well when did
she pass why like that Saturday night
[ __ ] it's all I landed I called home my
wife told me now and died that Monday I
went to that meeting for that guy that
Tuesday and then I think that that next
weekend was the weekend when the cat
died
and I got on my hands and knees and I
said so I was cleaned like four or five
[ __ ] days I was mad about the Marilyn
thing I was mad about I hadn't gone in
for the movie thing yet I think I did
going I was mad about the movie what
Marilyn came back I left her funeral as
their funeral was in Silver Lake and
then there was a cemetery a burial and I
can only make it to the funeral at the
church I couldn't make it to the burial
because I had him interview that day for
that movie it was all like like [ __ ]
up and I still remember going in that
day for the movie and being furious and
like that night was the benefit for
Marilyn at the store and I wasn't gonna
go and somebody go you have to go down
there she was your friend you have to go
now they represent and I was sober maybe
four or five days and I'm like [ __ ] this
is gonna be rough and I actually went
and stopped and got a package put it in
my pocket and went down it and that's
that I caused havoc with that poor
producer I caused havoc and they asked
me to leave the store didn't throw me
out they know it wasn't my fault but I
gave the package away and then that foul
on Wade Owen when I gave it up
officially but if it wasn't for Maryland
talking to me in that tone of voice I
would have probably still been doing
coke today so I want to thank Maryland I
wanna don't let you guys know about it
was taught twelfth anniversary I
appreciate Rick Ramos calling in and
that's it there's a Monday [ __ ] [ __ ]
Podcast [ __ ] nice and simple I
just wanted to tell you some things
about my life get you started for a
great week and let you know it's gonna
be a good [ __ ] here it's gonna happen
good and 2020 is gonna be even
[ __ ] better don'tdon't forget
listening Detroit I'll be there Thursday
and Friday and Saturday is already
sold-out Norma
listen right now at this point I got two
nights available in Miami
I got Friday the 28th and Saturday the
29th I think those the dates and
November go to my improv calm and double
check I went to Miami improv on Friday
the two late shows the sold-out she only
got you choice an early show and for the
following week and all I have is tickets
available for the 10:30 show at Town
Hall in New York City the early shows
there's tickets left but they're all
over on in 17 hours don't pay for those
[ __ ] things David that thing is the
Milan hours do not pay for scalpers
that's not yours no it's on the site
it's on the [ __ ] Town Hall site
whoa yes so don't know get those just
get shows it's New York they were out
for [ __ ] the fight last night though
1:00 in the morning it's comedy you
could stay up till midnight with uncle
Joey so it's the 29th and 30th whatever
the [ __ ] is Miami improv and then
December 6 tickets are still available
the 10:30 show in town hall real quick I
just want to talk to you about a few
people and then I'll get you out of here
CBB lime listen CBeebies everywhere
jesus [ __ ] christ there's a place by
the improv there you go and get my blood
test and they say that they make see me
these specialized - what the [ __ ] you
mean listen that's all great and dandy
but for right now I got what's gonna get
you to the next level you ready come in
CBD Lyon dot-com listen I approached
them
I tried their product I reached out to
them the rest is [ __ ] history
they sent me a box of the tensions and
the gummy bears and the shadder and the
vapor my wife does the vapor pen still
before she goes to bed I'm all out of
gummies I gotta get some more gummies
for them but the tensions I drink
[ __ ] 5,000 milligrams under my tongue
every night
I sleep like a [ __ ] baby you know
what this last week I did 66 points on
weight watches whatever the athletic
thing let me tell you some mistake helps
me recoup it helps my recovery
it takes down information CBB is the way
to go it's the future but there's a lot
of [ __ ] Mystics out there's a lot of
garbage out there don't be don't be
fooled CBB line com
go to their website they got third-party
test results and and they have the CBD
that you need to use for the particular
ailment who does that for you nobody go
to CBD line calm right now press in
church and get 20% off your first order
do not forget this and you get a little
older maybe you're young you're losing
your hair you're having some problems
you renege white to the [ __ ] get this
heart like it used to be never fear
uncle Joey's here the solution for him
is calm right now it's a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men listen the best way to
prevent more hair loss is to do
something about it while you still
forgot some left it's time to get a
handle on those precious locks okay this
Black Friday secured the best deal all
with a healthier thick a hair line
why do guys turn to weird solutions to
do nothing why they don't do dick and
you know it when you can turn to
medicine and science again I show up
with four hens calm a one-stop-shop air
wars
skincare and sexual wellness uncle Joey
what sexual wellness your [ __ ] pogo
stick ain't working maybe it gets erect
you know listen even if you got a good
dick why take a chance you're going on
the first a second third date get a
little extra help go in there and listen
for years all these fighters did
steroids what you know I have to do
steroids because you're gonna go get
some for chicka Stabbin go-to for him is
not calm right now you understand me no
more would been person doctor visits or
long pharmacy lines for him to connect
you with real doctors online which could
save you hours it's completely
confidential and discreet what you do is
you answer a few questions
to review it and then determine what's
right for you you can prescribe they can
prescribe a medication to treat hair
loss or
IDI that shipped directly to your door
nobody knows nothing
this Thanksgiving when your relatives
like oh my goodness you're looking
healthy and full they don't know they
don't know about your hand that you're
not a turkey and that was dangling
between your legs
it's a [ __ ] nightstick from the
police department you understand me
throw them for him calm right now listen
the church family right now gets
complete Hecate loss a complete hand
kick for five hours you'll enjoy what
are you talking about five hours right
now while supplies last and subject to
doctor's approval stop losing the hair
stop being the Momo in bed stop you know
cutting yourself short when you got help
listen right now go to the website for
full details and the safety information
for hems comm could cost you hundreds if
not thousands if you went to a doctor or
a pharmacy somewhere else I'm gonna get
you started for five hours today go to
forums comm slash Joey again go to for
hims comm slash Joey why walk around
looking like a Mook like a clown with no
hair and you dick don't work when you
got four hymns for hymns calm slash Joey
listen it's football season it's
basketball season and you're still not
asking yourself what the [ __ ] am I doing
with my life you're betting with a
bookie you got no options
my bookie AG gives you options they got
more prop bets than any other website
online and this year they're running a
super contest right now 100 aisles to
enter you pick five [ __ ] teams
a week against the spread and you rack
up the points at the end they count the
points first prize first place is
guaranteed on a thousand dollars well
winner [ __ ] you're gonna get that action
meanwhile you're betting five times
you bet those parlay cards and you're
winning every week for $11 give yourself
a break with some real money listen
their site just got revamped and it's
looking tremendous go take a look if you
haven't already
what I'm gonna do for you is why I like
my book is this you win you bet you win
you get paid what they gonna do right
now today Monday double your first
deposit use promo code Church CH you are
CH to get a hundred percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to a thousand
dollars Joey what does that mean that
means that if you put five hundred in my
bookie AG will match it who the [ __ ] is
better than you on a Monday morning
who's slinging dick like you on a Monday
morning
niente nobody so visit my bookie dot AG
today right now my bookie grab a pen my
B oh okay i e dot AG and don't forget to
use promo code Church when creating your
account to claim your bonus all right
and don't forget this Thursday let me
drop in one of my my bookie videos to
rock your [ __ ] world so one of my
boogie down AG pressing promo code
Church I want to thank my bookie I want
to thank for hims calm and I also want
to thank CBD lion calm but most
importantly I want to thank you [ __ ]
savages for always supporting the church
and having our back no matter what
do not forget Omaha sold on all four
shows are gone Detroit again they got
two thousand dollars think if you don't
want those wait till I go to Buffalo
cannon and you make a nice weekend you
tickets early and nobody gets your
fingers head I don't want nobody paint
over [ __ ] 40 [ __ ] dollars 35 32
plus a ticket charge I'm not no [ __ ]
Houdini I can't change your life one of
my Anthony [ __ ] Robins anyway Miami
December 6 at Town Hall of Late Show
10:30 besides that I love you
[ __ ] around my heart
alright the Christ killer loves you
thank you for supporting us thank you
for having I'm back I wanna thank our
sponsors again my bookie for hims
and CBD Lyon and that's it that's that
have a great week have a great day and
we'll see you [ __ ] Wednesday
tip-top [ __ ] Magoo take this
mealy